بعد أشهر من القتال العنيف،
ربما تكون معركة بحمود قد دفعت
رئيس فاغنر يفغيني بريغوسيان إلى حافة
الهاوية
[موسيقى]
واقفاً أمام جثث
مقاتليه الذين أطلقهم في هجوم صاخب
ضد القيادة العسكرية الروسية
وألقى باللوم عليهم في الوفيات التي حدثت
خلال أسبوع
تعتقد أنك أسياد هذه
الحياة، تعتقد أنك تستطيع التخلص من
حياة أخرى، تعتقد أن لديك
مستودعات مليئة بالذخيرة التي
لديك هذا الحق، وقد
غرق سيرجي شويجو وفاليري جيراسيموف، كبير جنرالات فلاديمير بوتين، في اقتتال داخلي شديد ولكن الآن
أصبحت خطب رئيس فاغنر
أكثر شراسة وأكثر تكرارًا حيث يتهم
وزير الدفاع الروسي بحجب
الذخيرة التي تشتد الحاجة إليها
بدلاً من استخدام قذيفة لقتل
عدو وإنقاذ حياة أحد جنودنا،
إنهم يقتلون جنودنا
في بلد سُجن فيه الآلاف
بسبب انتقادهم.
يفلت بريغوسان الحرب الخاص بفلاديمير بوتين من
نوبات غضبه، وذلك لأن بوتين لا
يثق تمامًا في جيشه ويحتاج إلى
فيرغسون،
ويعتقد الصحفي الاستقصائي الروسي أندريه سالداتوف أنه
مصاب بجنون العظمة الشديد بشأن السيطرة
والاستقرار السياسي، وأن بريغوسان أداة
إن لم يكن للحفاظ على القطار الأوسط.  تحقق
على الأقل لإبقائهم غير متوازنين
[تصفيق]
يبدو أن القتال يكلف روسيا
أرواحًا وزخمًا. يقول الجيش الأوكراني الآن
إنه يحقق مكاسب في بحمود،
بينما يقول الرئيس الأوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي إن
الهجوم المضاد الذي طال انتظاره لقواته
لم يبدأ بعد  التقدم اليوم
يتهم مرة أخرى الجيش الروسي
بقطع
الأراضي التي تم تحريرها
بدماء وأرواح رفاقنا
كل يوم والدخول إلى السلطة، والتي تتقدم بعشرات أو
مئات الأمتار خلال أشهر عديدة،
واليوم يتم التخلي عنها دون أي
قتال تقريبًا من قبل أولئك الذين  من المفترض أن نحافظ على
أجنحتنا
بوتين الأجنبي ولكن الآن يمكن أن يؤدي ذلك إلى
مشاكل كبيرة قادمة. يقول أندريه سالداتوف
أعتقد أنه متوتر لأنه علم أنه
لا يستطيع أن يثق تمامًا بما
يقوله له شعبه